Amy Schumer a comedian who's made her
career off of set your stopwatch I'm a
[ __ ]
and fat that's her career that's her
entire thing I I like eating I also like
being [ __ ]
that's her stick comedian Aaron glazier
was found guilty of rape we wrote about
this not where so much found guilty as
much as he was just accused no police
were actually involved no we wrote about
this some comedians came forward he
works at UCB in New York he's a comedian
now listen let me preface this by saying
he may be a rapist I don't know could be
a rapist I have no idea I just want to
preface that however look like a rapist
that's where you guys look like a rape
but has a beard in the glasses
it's hard to know if it's a rapist or a
hipster
women came forward said he had raped
them so he lost his job working at The
Upright Citizens Brigade theater I guess
he had a weekly show and he came out he
responded by Facebook and he said
recently one of our women have accused
me of sexual misconduct he said I didn't
do that I didn't do it and I've had no
recourse I don't know the names of the
women I don't know the accusations and I
don't know that there's been any
evidence presented and I've lost my job
and he's swearing up and down that he
has not done this okay he could have
done it my point so don't say you're a
rape apologist he absolutely could have
done it we have no idea that's why we
have a system of law that's what we have
courts so what happened here is someone
I guess who was friends with Amy Schumer
I don't think he writes for her
specifically that was a rumor out there
guy named Metzger Kurt Metzger I was get
it wrong with guy Mis comedian he has
like a shilling he's a comedian he has a
show and he took to Facebook so this is
important why I'm giving you all these
facets he said hey I know the cops
aren't always helpful that rapists don't
get convicted but they can't do anything
if you've never even gone to the cops
he said they can't help if you don't
bother going to the police at all why
aren't the rape kits being tested you
need to come forward and go to the cops
and convict this person that's what this
guy said he said if you were raped go
forward and convicted person as we've
been saying for a long time now you can
bring this up our resident favorite Amy
Schumer she tweeted out I am so saddened
and disappointed in Kurt Metzger he is
my friend and a great writer and I
couldn't be more against his recent
actions only 665 retweets this is
important when you look at these sites
or these people who have millions of
followers and they're retweets their
likes are not proportional you start to
see a shift in culture Amy Schumer a
comedian who's made her career off of
set your stopwatch I'm a [ __ ] and fat
that's her career that's her entire
thing I I like eating I also like being
[ __ ]
that's her stick I can't help it if I've
got a heavy flow and a wide-set vagina
but most people don't it's worn very
thin she felt the need that's her stick
to go forward and condemn a friend
saying I am totally against that what is
it that she's totally against she is
against him saying go to the police if
you are raped police may
if they don't do anything that's a
horrible problem we need to fix it but
they can't do anything if you don't go
to them she is mad that somebody a man
is trying to prevent more rapes Kurt
Metzger is trying to prevent more rapes
that's why I want to prevent more rapes
if this guy is going around raping
everybody in the Upper West Side or more
so the trendy village I don't know where
UCB is in the in New York City anymore
guess what you need to come forward and
get that guy convicted so he doesn't go
and rape somebody else that's what I
want men don't like rapists no we don't
want to see more women raped however
coming forward on social media is not
the same as going to the police I gave
him everything I always have a virgin
when I met him you don't care about
women who are going who could be raped
who could be future victims Amy Schumer
self professed feminist strong feminist
who also literally wants to take your
guns away up there with her Uncle Chuck
is saying I am so against somebody
believing in due process and thinking
that you should go to the police if
you're raped you should simply say the
words rape you don't even need to finish
the word just say rah and the guy is
guilty and loses his job there is nobody
nobody who wants to see rapists locked
away more than myself or more than
self-respecting non feminists strong she
got reaction of every guy out there I
wouldn't usual to kick their ass and you
hear about that you hear what that is
just it's too as a guy it's completely
naturally have you ever met a guy in
your life tweet me that's better have
you ever met a guy in your life when the
subject of rate came up he's like yeah
but secretly we're all on board right
yeah kind of that kind of thing I never
met anybody who's like out of left field
we're just talking like yeah rape it's
never once happened so this is why it's
so important because you're not going to
read about this at Gawker you're not
going to read about this you're not
going to hear about this in news what
you'll hear is man accused of rape and
that'll be it but I am sympathetic to
anybody anybody wanting due process what
this is why we have laws and you know
what you're doing you're belittling the
crime of rape we've talked about this
before when you say that one in four
women are raped which is entirely false
and when you fire people and say we find
this to be wildly offensive and
abhorrent this man has without any kind
of evidence and providing the person no
Reeko
you are absolutely belittling RIT not
only are you allowing people to get away
with a free pass this is a culture you
want to talk about rape culture the
culture is the social media outrage
culture where it is considered to be
just as productive to create a hashtag
or to come forward and just say I've
been raped with no legal process good
example is Facebook right we had this
incident with Facebook we had several
incidents where we knew that they were
they were screwing with our account a
report came out we had some billing
issues everybody else everybody else
with the big sites they got on and their
flamboyantly say we have these problems
and please help us
we took the proper legal action and
guess what we've been productive we've
been successful we've resolved it with
Facebook they're not screwing with their
page anymore we got the billing issue
resolved it's one thing to go forward in
social media to try and gain some
followers and that's what Amy Schumer is
doing and they've these people on the
rape side I'm like the Facebook side of
censorship which is they have the right
to do it but they're lying about it on
the right side people like Amy Schumer
are saying well going on Twitter is just
it's just as valid a reaction it's even
more valid because we're raising
awareness I mean that's just like the
rules of feminism oh you get away with
everything under that umbrella right
well why didn't you press charges I'm
just raising I'm too scared
I just I'm raising awareness well why
did you get a rape test test done you
can have the data no I'm just I'm
raising awareness really and you just
happen to be getting followers that's
how I get the word out about rape Lena
Dunham
wasn't raped maybe raped her sister Amy
Schumer no probably raped other people
and imagined before she was famous she
she had to get it any way she could any
which way she could
most of the high-profile celebrities who
come out have never pressed charges I've
never done anything about it
they've done precisely zero about it and
they make front-page news
well what do you think happens to a girl
who was actually violently raped in an
alleyway or someone who is sexually
accosted by their uncle or a coach makes
it a lot harder for them to come out
because it just becomes a white noise
well I was really raped yeah but is our
Amy Schumer Lena Dunham
dammit I guess I should just keep my
mouth shut
this video you might be a little
disturbed but this is taken from the
full weekly free podcast video cast you
can click to see the full show down
there or my face to go to ladder with
credit comm there are more articles than
you see here on YouTube or below me for
another video if you don't click any of
them that's fine but expect anthrax in
your mailbox